[MUSIC]
[APPLAUSE]
>> Aah!
Aah!
It's 2 AM on November 9th 2016.
I was alone in the middle of the street.
Shouting at the top of my lungs.
Donald Trump had just been announced as
the next President of the United States.
I was overcome by emotion and
the shouting was helping.
It was helping release some of that
emotional pressure I had been feeling.
A lot of people thought
a lot of things that day.
Some people were ecstatic.
Finally a president had been elected
that really understood their needs.
And others were really sad.
How could someone who had been so
divisive won?
For me, those feelings that night,
those shouts were all about anger.
I was angry because of the uncertainty I
knew a Trump presidency would bring for
my own country, Mexico.
I've thought a lot about that night.
What I did, what I could have done.
And you know what I would
have done if I could go back?
I would have gone into a library and
I would have run some regressions.
[LAUGH]
>> [LAUGH]
>> Today I'd like to tell you why,
with the hope that maybe by telling you
the way I dealt with those emotions,
it can help you figure out how to deal
with the emotions you might be feeling.
I was born and raised in Mexico.
I grew up in a family that has
always believed that Mexico and
the US should be closer together.
My dad was the chief architect and
negotiator for
Mexico at
the North American Free Trade Agreement.
I came to study college in the US.
I worked here after that.
I am about to graduate from two
Masters degrees here in the US.
I came to study and work in the United
States because I hope to live a life that
allows me to bring the two
countries closer together.
I love Mexico and I have a profound
admiration for the United States.
For me it's always been
obvious that bringing
our two countries closer
together is a good thing.
And yet Donald Trump seemed to stand for
completely the opposite of that.
I was so angry that night
because I couldn't help but
feel that he had won precisely because he
had promised to divide our two countries.
He literally promised to build
a wall between our two countries.
And that made me angry.
I was desperate to take action.
To do something, but
I didn't know what to do.
So instead, I started expressing my
emotions in all kinds of platforms.
WhatsApp, Facebook, emails,
in front of people.
Anything that I could do
to share how I was feeling.
I shared how I was angry.
How I hated that the US
was doing this to us.
I even said that I hated the US.
And to be honest all of Mexico
started doing the same.
And suddenly, the discourse in Mexico
towards the United States changed in a way
that it hadn't changed
in over three decades.
Anti-US feelings became the norm.
An extreme left wing presidential
candidate who is incredibly
anti-US is now the frontrunner for
the presidential elections in our country.
People started calling for
US companies to be kicked out of Mexico.
For tariffs to be imposed on US imports.
People started calling for
Mexico to push the US out.
When I saw that, all that anger
I had been feeling became worry.
Suddenly, Despite everything
I had been feeling and
saying, I realize that pushing the US
out was not the right course of action.
No, what we needed was finding
ways to keep letting the US in.
And so I set out to prove that with data.
I suddenly had something to do.
It wasn't the most exciting action,
but it was some action.
It consisted in locking
myself up in a library,
looking at datasets, and
running regressions.
We can think of what NAFTA
did in two big things.
One was that it lowered US tariffs for
Mexican products.
Those are the tariffs that
Donald Trump has threatened to raise.
The second thing it did is that it
lowered Mexican tariffs for US products.
Now Donald Trump gets to decide what
he wants to do with his tariffs, but
we as Mexico, we get to decide
what we want to do with ours.
And so the question for
me was what should we do with our tariffs?
Should we raise them and push the US out?
Or should we keep them at zero,
and keep letting the US come in.
The answer wasn't obvious.
Spent a lot of days in library.
But suddenly, l figured it out.
I was able to show that Mexico has
grown much more because Mexico lowered
its tarriffs on the US products.
Then because the US
lowered its tariffs on us.
That means that free trade
has been good for Mexico.
That means that businesses in our country
have grown because we opened up to the US.
That means that we
shouldn't push the US out,
but rather keep finding
ways to let them in.
Running those regressions gave me clarity.
I suddenly knew what I had to do,
I had to find ways from Mexico and
the US to keep in close to one another.
Even if my feelings were
telling me not to do that.
We are all feeling a lot
of things these days.
These are emotional times.
Some of us are facing the most challenging
issues many of us have ever seen.
And it's hard to overcome
the emotions we're feeling.
Sometimes they can paralyze us.
And other times it can jump us into action
that we maybe haven't fully thought out.
So today I want to ask you to
complement those emotions and
those feelings with data and analysis.
If you're feeling paralyzed, jump into
the data of whatever it is you care about.
And maybe that analysis will give
you clarity on how to move forward.
And if you are already jumping
into action, then maybe pause,
for a moment, and
make sure by looking at that data,
that what you are doing is going to help.
If you are marching and protesting,
keep marching and protesting.
But make sure you have
the data to back that up.
When I started preparing to give
this talk a couple months ago,
my intent was to argue that the way
we can counter the inflammatory and
outrageous statements made by
someone like Donald Trump,
is by being equally outrageous and
inflammatory ourselves.
And while that might feel good for
an instant, it's not going to do anything.
No, today more than ever, we need to
focus on facts, on data, on analysis.
So next time that you're feeling like you
want to Aah!, go run some regressions.
Thank you.
>> [APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC]